you said something earlier that i
thought was kind of profound is that
people need conflict
i do think they need conflict i think
people secretly like conflict
yeah it's like uh have you guys seen
wonder woman
not the new one the new one with uh gal
gadot yeah no no no
1984 like the good one that came out the
actual good one where so so that's
basically it like she thinks that if she
defeats the god of war aries
the war will stop and then chris pine's
character is like dude people
fight man like there's conflicts you
can't do anything about it
and then it's like ares all he does is
whisper in the ear he doesn't make the
war
he just you know nudges people in the
right direction to you know excite that
conflict
and like if he wasn't around and it just
built and built and built then it might
explode into some
some giant gorilla con i'm gonna move
this girl but some giant like
life-ending conflict so maybe a little
bit of conflict
frequently is healthier than letting it
build up
it didn't just automatically yeah just
a little bit relation i mean that's part
of why relationships i think
are like yeah you know you're married
yes that's being in being in
relationships a lot of like
people love that that and that you know
what i found today
the rage rooms are coming where you go
into a room
you break stuff yes it's kind of like
you know escape rooms are kind of thing
there's rage room now where you have a
hammer and they let you break whatever
you want in this room
interesting so you get some stress out
yeah that would
cover related stress yes yeah
i think it's cool i play a lot of games
to get my
my conflict resolution out of my system
sometimes but it's not not really
physical it's mostly mental
i didn't i didn't know about this rage
room yeah that's fascinating yeah we got
this i just pulled this up from
nbc why a rage room might be the key to
venting your bottled frustration
but rage rooms are not appropriate
treatment for everybody no i i couldn't
handle that
that's crazy to me that'll make it worse
yeah yeah i would not enjoy breaking
stuff and like going out like that
really
yeah i kind of would i don't know okay
you know everybody
everybody's got their own different way
of doing things they actually say about
catharsis that it's not necessarily good
it can make things worse
you know one of the things that i'm
starting to wonder during the course of
this conversation is that maybe
because we're not in relationships we're
not married and we don't have families
we don't want to break i mean yeah it's
not that you don't want to break stuff
but you don't have like the rock tumbler
effect of being in a long-term
relationship where you're just kind of
like knocking the rough edges off the
other person constantly and they're
doing the same for you and maybe that
leads to our
emotions being bottled up and yelling at
each other no i
i was just i was just thinking that um
because of something you said
earlier when you are talking about just
being busy with your family
because it's something we've absolutely
heard from a lot of other guests and a
lot of our friends where it's like
oh man you know with the school like
we've been so wrapped up i haven't been
following the news all that much you
know because i got two kids or whatever
that's what i hear a lot of and so i'm
thinking right now
you know what would end the culture war
seriously just end the protest make some
babies
yeah get something to do because then
they would have no choice but to be
wrapped up in family
yeah and something else matters just
your family yeah
they'd be productive they'd be working
and they'd be occupied yeah
idle hands are the devil's playground
but i suppose we should say
idol nethers yes are the devil's
playground
get it done yeah that's right no but i i
guess that's not the issue i think you
know people
actually no that is the issue yeah yeah
i was gonna say maybe people are still
hooking up
but they're not they're not having
babies no no no they're not even hooking
up that's true too
yeah yeah yeah like overwhelmingly gen z
is just like
a bunch of prudes no no no they can't
yeah i think of chemical castration not
really castration but like all these
weird new food chemicals that get added
and created in laboratories you know all
these new sugars sucralose
aspartame high fructose and and yeah
that's making
people's sex drive go down we've heard
testosterone
yeah but but ian to a hammer everything
looks like a nail and so you go
you go on these things about sugar and
then you make the assumption that these
things relate to these other problems
when if you actually look at the data
the reason for this has a lot to do with
social media
and dating websites pour all of it
together
and porn yeah absolutely now coven but
it was even before kova bakovic now
it's like oh i can't even that person's
mic oh well that's illegal in the uk
so what uh uh dating in the uk is it
really
yeah that's a crime you can't have sex
in the uk it's illegal
what what it is let me let me repeat
this it is a crime in the uk
to have sex with a person including brit
all the commonwealth unless you're in a
relationship with him i think
oh wow yeah i'm pretty sure i think what
carl benjamin
this is are headline news that
right seriously i saw where they
suggested yeah
yeah reuters it's from june 2nd
this is from last year british
government faces mockery over
chronovirus sex
ban yeah yeah
for keeping people safe under amendments
introduced in english rules on monday no
person may participate in a gathering
which takes place in public or private
and consists of two or more persons
britain
britain's tabloid media casted as the
bonking ban
what this is about making sure we don't
have people staying away from home at
night
uh-huh so two or more people so
two people can't be alone together
that's what they're saying legally yeah
yeah i mean this is like look at this
like pop the the google thing
yeah yeah october reuters uk banned sex
between government aid workers
october 16th sex ban england's coveted
tears october 25th uk's sex ban
explained june 4th coronavirus sex ban
dude it like
could you imagine if like joe biden came
out and was like
my fellow americans we're making sex
illegal
they'd be right come on man there'd be
riots huge riots
dude this is so it's creepy isn't it
that is dystopian it's it's i mean
[Laughter]
hyperbolic i'm not literally i don't
think i'm shattered but my dna is
shattering yeah
like i feel shaken with this news of
russia
in ukraine and then this social war
thing is like
i don't know what to do i could have
sworn i read something that
was sent to me by carl benjamin where it
was like the uk says you can't have sex
with somebody
and then also is just like some
high-ranking government officials
telling people to just go like crank it
out themselves
oh that's right you know i read some
good recommendations where you're
supposed to watch your partner jerk off
in front of you
but not get close to him or yeah that
was a
recommendation from the government
that's weird we're not family friendly
on friday night
yeah yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry guys no i
mean i i i brought it
yeah but i mean it's it's it's like
the ultimate authoritarianism i suppose
that if
we're like social media is a problem
it's it's making young people not have
families and then suddenly we're like
and then they have no purpose yes it's
true you know what's really funny
is because i don't have kids see it's my
own fault i've been talking about how
millennials and then the these
generations have no purpose
so i did this video a while back about
you know how jordan p
peterson provided purpose to many young
men find the heaviest thing you can
carry and carry it
and then wokeness was the purpose for
these leftists
so you have these young people who are
sitting there like why am i alive
and then like hitting themselves in the
head screaming and so they searched for
anything and some people found wokeness
it's almost it's almost like you guys
have watched underworld yeah
no you've never seen it you know where
like the the the corvid what is it
called
the court venus yeah yeah it's like
basically this dude's got this like
immortality thing
and then one son is bitten by a bat and
one son's bitten by a wolf and then it
creates the two different tribes the
werewolves and the vampires
so you have these people who like drift
into one tribe or the other sjw anti-sjw
because they're trying to find some
purpose in their lives and
you know like like i mentioned jordan
peterson provided purpose to a lot of
these young men the left absolutely
hated it
but then i realized that you know my
perspective was lacking
because i don't have kids the real
purpose missing from these people's
lives is family
yes just outright the the people before
these generations didn't have idle hands
weren't desperate for a purpose they had
kids they had like 10 kids
yeah my great-grandmother had 12 kids
i'm like
whoa how do you do that it's crazy now
it's frowned upon
yeah how's your life changing like
how what how different is it what what
what have you
has your social perception changed since
you've been raising a family or raising
children
a child uh the world scares the crap out
of me
what aspects of it just
what kind of future my son is going to
be into and how
how can i change that and i think i've
changed my commentary a lot
where i've been you know i want to make
a difference a positive difference in
people's lives
where before you know i was a little bit
trolly i'm still a little bit trolly
but i feel like i want to make an impact
in the world because for my son
and hopefully future children's sake i'm
also
scared of pedophiles oh yeah i feel
like there's so many out there
creepy people the epstein thing was a
conspiracy theory
it was a conspiracy theory for years and
alex jones was
mocked relentlessly for talking about
these things
and then mike cernovich and a reporter
in from the i think the miami herald i'm
not sure started filing lawsuits they i
think they then joined
i could begin the story wrong but they
were both very much going after these
files and then
all of a sudden it was like boom this is
real
this happened you know the documents
were there and you were called crazy if
you said that these high-profile people
like harvey weinstein for instance
granted he's a bit different but still
these like ex like
these are extreme instances of severe
predation
and you were a conspiracy theorist it
wasn't true even though
like the crazy things like seth
macfarlane family guy jokes
would make fun of kevin spacey and
harvey weinstein and you were wondering
like what do these people actually know
in these industries so so so definitely
but
i also wonder if i don't know just
what can you do for your son's future
you know what i mean let me let me get
more um
nuanced i hear a lot from people who
have kids where they're like i have to
make sure i'm around for my kids
but then they're willing to sacrifice
the bigger picture for the for the for
for their kids you know what i mean like
they're willing to say i'll forgo this
conflict and risking myself to fight
for these ideas because it's better that
i can be there for my kids to give them
food
than it is that i defend the future yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you